es gibt einen deal erleichterung in
brüssel und london
doch ob das britische parlament dem
rexit zustimmt ist offen kritik an trump
syrien strategien demokraten und
republikaner verurteilen den
truppenabzug
wut und empörung der bundestag
debattiert über den anschlag von halle
und die folgen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
für den sport norbert könig sehr gerne
genommen wer hätte das gedacht
großbritannien könnte doch noch zum 31
oktober aus der eu austreten und zwar
geregelt denn es gibt ein neues abkommen
den durchbruch verkündeten ein sichtlich
zufriedener britischer premier johnson
und eu-kommissionspräsident juncker
allerdings könnte die freude nur von
kurzer dauer sein denn es ist mehr als
fraglich ob das britische unterhaus
überhaupt zustimmt dazu gleich mehr
zunächst zeigt an seinem stern was
vereinbart wurde
der neue brachse deal hat ein zentrales
versprechen keine harte eu-außengrenze
zwischen dem britischen nordirland und
dem eu mitglied irland hier an der
landgrenze auf der irischen insel soll
es keine zollkontrollen geben
die nordiren mit einer besonderen rolle
sie sind im zollgebiet des vereinigten
königreiches aber sie gehen auch in eine
sogenannte zoll partnerschaft mit der eu
heißt es gelten weiter die eu
binnenmarktregeln allerdings nur vier
jahre dann entscheidet das nordirische
parlament ob es so bleibt feststeht
waren die nordirland verlassen oder
erreichen sollen direkt an den
nordirischen häfen und flughäfen
kontrolliert werden großbritannien geht
nach dem dreck zieht formal raus aus dem
binnenmarkt der eu will aber europäische
standards garantieren etwa bei
lebensmitteln beim umweltschutz oder bei
den rechten von arbeitnehmern
ob dieser neue deal jetzt tatsächlich
realität wird das ist allerdings völlig
offen
vor einer stunde haben zumindest schon
mal die eu staats und regierungschefs in
brüssel das neue abkommen gebilligt und
ihre unterstützung für eine schnelle
umsetzung zum 31 oktober zugesagt von
einem ereignisreichen tag in brüssel
berichtet bürger ein händedruck der
chefs ein foto mit den unterhändlern es
zeigt den moment in dem briten und
europäer mal wieder die scheidung
einreichen
garniert mit einer drohung wir haben
eine vereinbarung
und das bedeutet auch wir haben keinen
grund für eine weitere fälle uniqa des
promis den baxter hat er abgeräumt den
binnenmarkt haben sie geschützt und doch
die stars des gipfels sind zaungäste
zustimmen müssen abgeordnete in
straßburg und in london
ich hoffe jetzt sehr dass sich unsere
abgeordneten in westminster einigen
diese entscheidung für das britische
parlament in vollständiger freiheit
fällen und deshalb haben wir uns mit der
frage was passiert wenn nicht befasst
was wenn london ablehnt juncker hat
johnson heute eine vielleicht hilfreiche
antwort gegeben wir trennen uns mit
dieser oder ohne jede vereinbarung frage
ist ob die europäer ihre drohung
wahrmachen aus brüssel und london sind
jetzt unsere korrespondentinnen
zugeschaltet zunächst nach brüssel anne
gellinek wer hat sich da jetzt mehr
durchgesetzt
der vertrag ist ein klassischer
kompromiss der versuch die roten linien
von beiden seiten irgendwie unter einen
hut zu bringen
die einigung ist möglich geworden als
die briten eingesehen haben dass eine
komplette wirtschaftliche abkoppelung
nordirlands von der eu eine harte grenze
nach sich ziehen würde
die eu musste dafür die kröte schlucken
dass die nordiren de facto ein vetorecht
haben über die praxis regeln in
nordirland die meisten der staats und
regierungschefs die sich heute hier im
gipfel gebäude versammelt haben wirkten
sehr erleichtert bei ihrer ankunft und
übten sich in zweckoptimismus boris
johnson werde es schon irgendwie
schaffen das abkommen durchs parlament
zu bringen
allerdings gab es auch nervös nervöse
töne eu-kommissionspräsident juncker
drohte nach london
es werde keine weitere verschiebung des
praxis geben dieses diese warnung
allerdings fingen die bundeskanzlerin so
eben gerade wieder ein
sie sagte man habe den britischen
parlament keine vorgaben zu machen
wenn die eu die wahl hat zwischen
verlängerung und chaos praxis lässt sie
sich lieber ein hintertürchen offen
das britische parlament stimmt über
morgen über den neuen vertrag
jana zimmermann wie stehen die chancen
dass er durch geht sicherlich eine gute
idee sich ein hintertürchen offen zu
lassen denn hier ist die lage mal wieder
durchwachsen boris johnson hat ja keine
eigene mehrheit im parlament und die
nordirischen unionisten die seine
regierung eigentlich stützen haben schon
gesagt sie akzeptieren den dielen nicht
weil er sonderregelung für nordirland
beinhaltet dann sind da noch die
konservativen abgeordneten die boris
johnson wegen ungehorsams letzten monat
aus der partei geschmissen hat die
mustern und versuchen wieder
zurückzugewinnen
und selbst wenn ihm das gelingen sollte
fehlen immer noch ein gutes dutzend
stimmen die hofft er bei labour
abgeordneten zu finden deren wahlkreise
für den bhc rexit gestimmt haben und die
die rache ihrer wähler fürchten müssen
wenn sie den wechsel jetzt nicht helfen
zu liefern
wer am ende aus erschöpfung angst oder
überzeugung wie abstimmt das kann man
hier wirklich nicht vorhersagen
wahrscheinlich wissen ist einige der
abgeordneten selbst noch nicht und das
einzige was hier sicher scheint ist das
das ergebnis knapp und der samstag hoch
dramatisch wird vielen dank für diese
einschätzung nach london und größere
diana zimmermann und anne gellinek eine
einigung mal wieder in letzter minute
wie es weitergeht so wie alle
entwicklungen begleiten wir unter
heute.de mit einem live-blog außerdem
finden sie dort ausführliche analysen
unser korrespondenten zum krieg in
syrien
da versucht us-vizepräsident pence den
türkischen präsidenten erdogan von einer
waffenruhe zu überzeugen im norden
syriens
es ist eine vermittlungsmission im
auftrag jobs dessen syrien politik nicht
nur international sondern auch im
eigenen land heftig kritisiert wird ein
treffen mit der frontfrau der demokraten
nancy pelosi endete mit einem eklat
zuvor hatte es für jump eine klatsche im
repräsentantenhaus gegeben ines trams
berichtet
abreise präsident tom heutigen texas
ganz ohne worte er ist unter druck auf
einer pressekonferenz mit dem
italienischen präsidenten hatte er
gestern noch versucht den abzug aus
nordsyrien zu rechtfertigen auch die
bislang verbündeten kurden im stich zu
lassen
ich will nicht verwickelt werden in
einen krieg zwischen der türkei und
syrien
insbesondere mit blick auf die kurden
und ich sage das mit großem respekt sie
sind keine engel wärme rangers scharfen
gegenwind bekommt trump auch aus den
eigenen reihen in einer überparteilichen
resolution verurteilt das
abgeordnetenhaus den syrien abzug
ähnliches plant trumps enger vertrauter
und gewöhnlich kritisch lindsay graham
heute im senat
anfangs händen wird amerikanisches blut
kleben der sogenannte es wird eher
starken wenn er die kurden allein lässt
führt dann auch nur ein amerikaner
ermordet trägt er verantwortung
kramp veröffentlicht nun einen brief von
ihm an den türkischen präsidenten
erdogan der belegen soll
er habe die türkische syrien offensiven
nicht abgesegnet undiplomatisch voller
trump erdogan darin auf weder ein narr
zu sein noch den starken zu geben
überzeugen konnte trump jedoch wieder
erdogan noch die spitze der demokraten
im kongress ein treffen mit traum endete
im eklat franck ist ausgeflippt traurig
er nannte sie eine drittklassige
politikerin
ich habe entgegnet ich wünschte sie
wären ein politiker zur stunde versucht
rams vizepräsident penz in ankara
erdogan zu einer waffenruhe nordsyrien
zu bewegen
alles deutet darauf hin dass die türkei
ihre offensive nicht stoppen wird in
chorbane in nordsyrien kämpften einst us
truppen gemeinsam mit den kurden gegen
den es jetzt ist die strategisch
wichtige stadt wieder zum brennpunkt
geworden
in der nacht bezogen syrische regierung
soldaten dort stellen
urbane liegt an der türkisch syrischen
grenze in dem 30 kilometer breiten
streifen aus dem die türkei die kurden
milizen vertreiben will
um eine sogenannte sicherheitszone zu
schaffen zakopane ist zürich
und dort steht für uns thomas gill
thomas wie ist die aktuelle situation
und was bedeutet dieser einmarsch der
us-truppen in kubaner ja wir sind
unmittelbar an der türkisch syrischen
grenze intern cisco bahne
und wir haben wir haben den ganzen tag
hier auch vereinzelte gefechte gehört
die regierungstruppen assad sind gestern
abend in das stadtzentrum vom kubaner
eingefahren
das ist wahrscheinlich in absprache auch
mit den kurdischen milizen passiert die
sich dann zurückgezogen haben und das
durchkreuzt mit sicherheit die pläne von
erdogan denn der will ja eine viel
größere pufferzone und zwar mit globale
und das könnte so etwas sein wie eine
zäsur in der türkischen offensive gegen
die kurdischen milizen im nordosten
syriens dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus so ritsch thomas
gebauer das und aus sicherheitsgründen
haben wir das interview am späten
nachmittag aufgezeichnet
spanien ist weiter unter druck in der
katalonien frage regionalpräsident
toller droht mit einer weiteren
abstimmung über die unabhängigkeit
kataloniens er reagiert damit auf die
langen haftstrafen gegen
separatistenführer auch heute gingen
wieder viele menschen aus protest auf
die straße in der nacht gab es in
barcelona wieder schwere ausschreitungen
zwischen der polizei und demonstranten
mit dutzenden von verletzten nach
deutschland der anschlag von halle vor
gut einer woche hat drängende fragen
aufgeworfen vor allem was tun gegen
wieder aufflammenden antisemitismus
politiker im bundestag haben in einer
sondersitzung antworten gesucht und
antworten gegeben
auch auf kommentare die aus den reihen
der afg verbreitet wurden und viele
empörte patrick niedermeier über eine
emotionale debatte
es ging heute immer wieder um halle und
die folgen am morgen gedachten die
abgeordneten der opfer in jeder rede war
es thema selbst der bundestagspräsident
ergriff das wort überwältigende mehrheit
der menschen in unserem lande empfindet
den anschlag von alles so wie es unser
bundespräsident bezeichnet hat als
schande als eine schande sahen fast alle
auch den retweet des fdp-abgeordneten
brandner in dem gefragt wurde warum
politiker mit kerzen in moscheen und
synagogen rumlungern wenn doch die opfer
deutscher sein
ich fordere sie einfach auf distanzieren
sie sich vor zwischen der tief sei nur
ein beispiel dafür dass die afg das
klima für rechtsextremistische gewalt
geschaffen habe auch für den täter von
halle
er wird getragen von einem system der
hetze des chauvinismus und des
rechtsextremismus und die afd ist teil
dieses systems nicht die afg sondern die
willkommenskultur von 2015 habe zu einer
gewaltigen radikalisierung geführt
konnte alexander gauland die
beispiellose hetze mit der meine partei
in den vergangenen tagen überzogen wurde
war der erwartbare versuch uns eine
mitschuld zu geben ist fertig gebracht
ausgerechnet sie von der ard als opfer
darzustellen das ist wirklich der
schande
auch der bundespräsident möchte sich am
abend in die debatte ein und warnte vor
einer weiteren verrohung der sprache
jeder der hass schürt bereitet boden für
gewalt und jeder der für hass und hetze
für rechtsextremismus und fremdenhass
auch nur ein funken verständnis
aufbringt der macht sich mitschuldig
es war ein tag mit harten emotionalen
debatten und am nachmittag mit einer
entschuldigung des fdp-abgeordneten
brandner für sein retreat immerhin tempo
130 auf deutschen autobahnen das wollen
die grünen und sehen darin einen beitrag
zu mehr verkehrssicherheit und für mehr
klimaschutz
mit ihrem vorstoß sind sie heute im
bundestag gescheitert 498 abgeordnete
stimmten gegen ein tempolimit 126 dafür
deutschland ist das einzige land ohne
ein generelles tempolimit in der bieten
thüringen welt in zehn tagen einen neuen
landtag wie schwierig die
regierungsbildung werden könnte zeigt
das zdf politbarometer
danach hätte weder die amtierende rot
rot grüne koalition eine mehrheit noch
eine koalition aus cdu spd und grünen
wenn am sonntag landtagswahl wäre käme
die cdu auf 26 prozent die linke auf 27
und die spd auf 9
die afg läge bei 20 prozent die grünen
bei 8 und die fdp bei 5
jeder dritte wähler ist noch
unentschieden
und noch was zeigt das zdf
politbarometer
mobilität ist den thüringern wichtig und
dass ihr internet läuft beides nämlich
liegt im argen die verkehrs und die
netzanbindung besonders auf dem land
tragen nicolas berichtet
der thüringer wald bei schmalkalden die
idylle kann zum problem werden wenn
internetanschluss und handyempfang
schlecht sind also ganz konkret kam es
einfach wirklich dazu dass
geschäftsreisende
unser hotel nicht wieder aussuchen
konnten weil einfach die
internetverbindung so schlecht war dass
sie ihre arbeit abends nicht erledigen
konnten 40.000 euro für eine extra
internetleitung könne er nicht zahlen
ja aber sie deshalb bund und land in der
pflicht 80 prozent der thüringer leben
ländlich ob bahn bus oder behörden
infrastruktur hier oft wichtigstes thema
so auch in hesel ried ein ortsteil von
hildburghausen nahverkehr heißt hier
seit jahren drei schulbusse an werktagen
am wochenende fährt nicht viel dafür sie
halt abgehängt also wirklich wahrsten
sinne des wortes das trifft 1300
menschen in hesel ried besonders die
älteren einkaufsmöglichkeiten und
verwaltung sind über zwei kilometer
entfernt wir hatten zwei schulen
kindergarten kinderkrippe zwei
verkaufsstellen mehr hatten die burg
stelle mehr der bürgermeister wird schon
nix mehr auch der letzte treffpunkt der
dorfgasthof ist abgerissen das haus
hatte die stadt zuvor verkauft ersatz
dafür gab es bislang nicht verwaltung
öffentliche infrastrukturen sind immer
auch ein zeichen wie der staat sich den
menschen gegenüber präsentiert
und wenn die öffentlich der öffentliche
raum verwahrlost dann sehe ich eben auch
dass der staat sich eigentlich für die
menschen in der region nicht wirklich
interessiert ein weitreichendes problem
gerade im ländlichen bestimme die
infrastruktur das bild der menschen auf
staat und politik und jetzt noch was für
alle freunde von frischen
sonntagsbrötchen die brauchen künftig
nicht mehr extra früh aufzustehen um zum
bäcker zu gehen das hat der
bundesgerichtshof klargestellt wenn die
bäckerei über ein angeschlossenes café
verfügt darf auch sonntags mehr als drei
stunden verkauft werden
solche bäckerei cafés gelten juristisch
als gaststätten und dürfen deswegen brot
und brötchen von früh bis spät abgeben
und damit hätten wir dann auch schon die
passenden stichworte für das topspiel
der bundesliga
backwerk wortspiele die eine borussia
muss im moment kleinere brötchen backen
und die andere will sich nicht die
butter vom brot nehmen lassen das heißt
im klartext lucia fabres dortmunder
dümpeln unerwartet im mittelfeld der
tabelle herum während marco rose mit
mönchengladbach ganz selbstbewusst die
tabellenführung verteidigen will am
samstagabend beim bvb lucia phase
durchlebt in dortmund unruhige zeiten
gleich dreimal nacheinander hat sein
team bei eigener führung nur 2 2
gespielt zuletzt in freiburg sogar per
eigentor
statt 9 gab es dafür nur spärliche drei
punkte und platz acht der tabelle setzt
den trainer spürbar unter erfolgsdruck
wissen wenn wir müssen müssen unbedingt
empfohlen unbedingt gewinnen das ist
klar
zur westfälischen kommt die
niederrheinische borussia als frecher
tabellenführer mit den neuen trainer
marco rose hat sich mönchengladbach
offenbar auch dem erfolg verpflichtet
am samstag in dortmund droht nun ein
echtes spitzenspiel
keine tore aber eine menge zündstoff in
pjöngjang nach der rückkehr vom
historischen bruderduell im fußball
berichtet südkoreas nationalteam wenig
erbauliches vom null zu null in
nordkorea von der anderen seite hört man
nichts die reaktionen nach dem
geisterspiel der koreanischen
kontrahenten hätten nach der ankunft der
südkoreaner in soul nicht heftiger
ausfallen können
es war wie krieg ich habe noch nie so
ein aggressives spiel gesehen beim
nächsten mal werden wir sie bestrafen
von der begegnung gibt es lediglich
fotos keine bewegtbilder aggressivität
ist auf den veröffentlichungen nicht zu
erkennen wohl aber dass zuschauer fehlen
an die beleidigungen will ich mich nicht
erinnern und das die zuschauer fehlten
hat mich nicht überrascht
bei den winterspielen von finjan noch
harmonie mit einer gemeinsamen
koreanischen olympia mannschaft doch
davon ist man derzeit weit entfernt
fifa-boss gianni infantino ärgerte sich
als zeuge des spiels
über leere ränge und den ausschluss der
medien zum fatalen handy video gemacht
das wetter zeigt sich windig und
regnerisch im westen noch länger sonnig
und trocken im osten die details hat
gleich katja honnefer im heute-journal
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
christian sievers wir danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen noch einen
sehr schönen abend bis morgen wenn sie
werden auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
ist wirklich eine eindrucksvolle wolken
spirale die sich nicht nur einmal
sondern 23 ja vielleicht sogar vier mal
ein kringelt sie bringt uns immer wieder
wolken auch regen und was wir unseren
keinen fall bringt ist kälte so war es
auch heute nachmittag wieder sehr mild
in deutschland mit 14 grad zum beispiel
auf sylt und 20 grad in freiburg
jetzt kommt von frankreich gleich wieder
der nächste regen heran der erreicht in
dieser nacht bereits den nordosten dann
gibt es eine kurze regenpause bis der
nächste regen von frankreich heran kommt
bei tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 13 und 6
kraft morgen vormittag ist es dann
zwischen der ostseeküste dem alpenrand
häufig freundlich im westen allerdings
regnet ist und diese dichterin
regenwolken erreichen bis zum nachmittag
auch den osten und westen kannst dann
kräftige gewitter geben westlich des
rheins allerdings da locker die wolken
am nachmittag auf dazu frischt der wind
bis zum abend durch auf sturmböen
erwarten wir aber am ehesten noch über
dem ärmelkanal über den niederlanden und
über der nordsee
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 13 und 21 grad und wechselhaft
und eher mild geht es danach auch weiter
schönen abend noch